we were running behind schedule and I
had to shoot a montage oh my god this
this montage would have taken like five
days so what I did is I I came in there
and brought everyone into one big room
all the dancers and had three cameras
I took one camera and just stayed with
John Travolta and I worked with him and
the rest I said to everyone just dance
and do whatever you want
cartwheels I say catch it all whatever
and then I sent a camera down when
they're making the stage and we just
with regular light I said and just shoot
what you can just no sound nothing and
we put it all together and save four
days of filming but none of that
absolutely zero was choreographed even
if funny I say okay John just do this
yeah cut do this cut and then is what I
got and then the other dancers were just
over there in the corner the scratchy
and doing a somersault stretching and
you put it all together so there are no
rules yeah it's always sure and I even
put it in Rocky through that you know
he's I'm afraid I'm afraid the fear is
but the fear is the fuel that we use for
overachievement
if I wasn't afraid at times I wouldn't
work as hard and because the fear is I
don't want to sit back into mediocrity I
don't want to just say okay I want to
rest on my laurels so I'm I hear
footsteps all the time and I know that I
only have a certain amount of time and I
don't want to waste it because I it's
gone so quickly there's only a certain
amount of productivity and
waste you just watched two amazing clips
from Sylvester Stallone take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]